oh man how you guys like the new angle
enjoy it for one more episode because
after this episode we are no more I'm
gonna be in this house welcome back
welcome welcome
exhausted version but somehow even more
exhausted than we were last week
amazingly yeah in better spirits but
definitely more exhausted yeah I mean
you can't see a house in this shot but
basically everything is gone except for
some big pieces of furniture that we're
gonna move at 9 a.m. in the morning yeah
legs all gone it's a I this house has
never looked ever since we moved in it
hasn't looked this clean and empty and
skeleton like but it's exciting because
as we empty this house our new place is
getting more and more comfy and feeling
like we're ready to live in it so well
yeah cuz we've been slowly moving over
like boxes of stuff and then we're
planning on just having a movie well
it's not even a moving company
it's Rome's husband and his friends just
come help us with the big stuff so yeah
we're moving big stuff tomorrow but
we've already taken nine trips to the
new house right nine of tenzin I thought
yeah just in Jenna's car she's got the
SUV so we fold down the chairs and
loaded up with boxes so it's been it's
been a lot but like Jenna said earlier
all you know the hard part is behind us
not only just you know packing up your
[ __ ] is the worst part okay what was
your least favorite part about packing
um room and I know I think my least
favorite part about packing was the fact
that you would spend a lot of time what
can I help you you spend a lot of time
doing one thing and when you finish
you're like ah man and you look look
everywhere and there's [ __ ] everywhere
even put a dent yeah it's so
discouraging it's really discouraging so
um yeah so I think that I mean just the
feeling of being in like an abyss of
stuff it was pretty hard but I mean you
she better not go anyway sorry you dealt
with it really well you get your nose to
the grindstone um I had to work today
yeah and you thought I was there hey
come here
she's we have like a bench that's out
that has like a padding on top did you
sniffing it like she's gonna piss on it
as she better know to go to peach okay
you better not hmm oh my god
I have to say that my least favorite
part about packing was the [ __ ]
fake Christmas trees that were still up
so I I took down the little one in the
bedroom and everything was you know
[ __ ] covered in glitter there's
glitter everywhere there's glitter on
this table right now it's you can never
get rid of it it's [ __ ] everywhere
and then so we threw out the little box
for the little Christmas tree and so I
[ __ ] wrestled it into a flat wardrobe
box but that was the only time like I'm
been sort of like sweaty and gross since
we started packing or whatever but like
I legit was breaking out in a sweat
trying to get that [ __ ] Christmas
tree in a [ __ ] box it was the worst
thing that I did the entire time it's a
free spirit didn't want to be put in a
box you know and we still didn't even we
didn't do the entire the big Christmas
tree in the living room like everyone
make fun of me on YouTube like is there
a Christmas tree like it's July like no
[ __ ] is now October yeah it's
still up we almost made it but like half
of it has been moved
yeah half it is because the box for it
I put outside in the little shed and it
got [ __ ] destroyed because the [ __ ]
is plastic it doesn't insulate anything
huh but it's fine because we took off
this is riveting I know guys this is
riveting but we took off we took off the
top half of the tree in two parts and
moved it already so all we have is the
bottom half anyway these Christmas trees
man that's why I left them up because I
did not want to [ __ ] just like you
and they're also there's not really I
mean other than that little teeny shout
outside there's not really many places
to put it I mean in this house this
house there's no we place the new place
there's there's places that we have a
whole zombie apocalypse room where it's
like we just put all our crap that we're
going to calling it the utility room or
the totally-tiffany I like I like
utility shelter okay so it's like that's
where we go when [ __ ] goes down yeah I
like doing water and my sewing machines
in there gun I got my bowling shoes golf
clubs yeah like it's like walking yeah
that's the room where it will go down
and there's a there's a sweet interest
there's a secret entrance to that room
so you can go out the back which is
really cool it's like a really odd room
but you know what we're gonna use that
[ __ ] for when it goes down in there and
do mad activities yeah and uh it's got
like it's not quite like a shelf it's
not quite like a tool you know the area
it's it's like sort of like a
woodworking class yeah it's like cabinet
but on top there's like a flat area
where you can actually like do projects
so many activities we can do activities
in there but we're really exciting this
new place in terms of us you know
well shooting videos we're gonna any to
everything and everything is just going
to be improved I feel like because we're
gonna have we moved a little further
away from Atlanta we're having a little
more space yeah we moved to the burbs
dog we into burbs except it's like
popping over there man yeah it's more
exciting there than it is here yeah I
was not familiar with you know how
popular was but I'm excited so like we
in that valley dick we're in the valley
we got some I think there's yeah baby
officially in the valley
it's almost cheaper out there and you
get so much more for you money and what
I've been thinking this entire time
living anywhere in Los Angeles like get
me Los Angeles is super pretentious it
was really funny I was texting Brett
today and he was like what's your new
address so I texted it to him and I was
like I was like you know it's Sherman
Oaks you know but I said I sent an
address with Sherman Oaks as the city
but in maps on my phone the Apple Maps
when you type in the address that says
Los Angeles and he laughed and I was
like scumbag Maps moved to Sherman Oaks
away from the pretentious area still
says you live in LA
but yeah we're at we're out of the we're
out of the LA scene which is exciting
yeah and well the place is a little bit
bigger square footage which but we're
saving money it's like a mindfuck use
you move over the hill and then you just
well what I mean I'm Santa Monica to
hear it was the same thing I'm like
seriously yeah just [ __ ] proximity to
the ocean and [ __ ] and then you pay
out the ass like how Los Angeles how do
you work like you were just like there's
a hub of I didn't even live close to the
ocean no it's like [ __ ] 30 blocks oh
you oh [ __ ] yeah like that least I think
there's I was peering out at the Pacific
every day yeah I mean well first of all
there's north of Montana which is really
a wealthy area and then like Brentwood I
didn't live there I'm not saying you did
I'm just trying to explain like why it's
expensive in Santa Monica I think first
of all north of Montana then you have
Brentwood and Beverly Hills and of
course but that's East but so Martha
Montana Brentwood and then it's like
there's like a hub of wealthy mid area
it's not really close to the water but
not really
inland like us like you lived among
champions yeah so that's like where tom
brady and giselle live yeah arnold
schwarzenegger live but to answer like
it doesn't really make sense live up
there I'm rocking him that's right a day
I drove down rocky we've seen his house
right no I think it was my brother or my
mom knows my dad really wanted to drive
down that street and like really dad
wasn't my dad
I don't know I wasn't there oh wait was
that maybe you think you're there for
like a day when he visited yeah but we
went we just went through yeongjong Oh
Jay Street like is [ __ ] weird mr.
morri we went to we went to Malibu for
dinner but then I had a little big but
um yeah mr. Maurice - Maurice let's go
see go slow red want to go slow wrinkles
for I want the story in that wealthy
hood of Brooklyn and go see what Oh Jay
used to live it's so wealthy for no
reason why is it wealthy anyway where
I'm couldn't be like I've been a
Southern California person my whole life
I was born and raised he was born in
Northern California but I was raised
Southern California I've lived all kind
of all over like West Los Angeles covert
city Santa Monica
but I'm excited to have like a new
experience in the valley I feel like you
know the fact that we're both going to
be discovering this place together at
the same time for the first time yeah
that's a cool thing and it's also good
because you know I you know I could use
a change I'm kind of over what's right
here I know I don't really fit in to a
lot of places in Los Angeles I feel like
and I'm sure whoever's listening to this
or watching that could understand why I
kind of marched to my own drum yeah
which is the opposite of people here
they're all there are Hollywood sheep
well no not everybody sheep no there's
definitely really cool people here but
they're very difficult to find yeah it
takes a farm few Pettine but this week a
couple of years to find people that
you're like oh you're you're not an
[ __ ] okay you can say well it's just
frustrating because yes everywhere you
go you're going no matter how much work
you have to put in there are going to be
good people it's just frustrating to
think that this area condones the
reality that you have to just expect
people off the bat to be self-absorbed
people that you don't really want to see
and if they're nice it's kind of like Oh
surprise well yeah well okay I guess
this past this podcast is turning into a
conversation the different than we
expected but I just have a question for
you I guess because I'm you know I want
to know because a lot of people that
live in Los Angeles are like myself for
transplants we come here from other
places in the country so in theory this
place should be like the coolest [ __ ]
melting pot ever you know like everyone
that has similar sort of interests moves
to a hub and then you know in theory it
should just be like this happy like yay
time like you know you find your [ __ ]
cool place it's not everyone here kind
of sucks and doesn't have a soul uh when
you were growing up yeah what was your
experience with people in Southern
California it does it like does it
trickle down to the children are
children [ __ ] like are they
pretentious like what or are they
regular people because your friends are
super normal
um yeah you know I think well from when
I was like Little League I remember
there were a couple kids on teams I
played with who
definitely like rich you want to smack
them well you know I mean as a kid you
don't really want but he grows up with
somebody that's rich yeah and like I
think as a kid I didn't really grasp uh
or maybe I just didn't meet real snobs
but I didn't really grasp the fact that
you know wealth can breed
you know arrogance and annoy yeah yeah
yeah so I was just like Oh your house is
bigger than mine and we're eating sushi
for lunch or whatever not me and it
always wanted to go over the other
people's house yeah and so everybody's
house was bigger than that yeah so I
think some some like literally and then
when you got to high school I feel like
I mean I I'm only speaking for myself I
went to Santa Monica High School it's
it's right in the heart of Santa Monica
it's actually closer yeah it's close Sam
oh that's right it's closer to like
Venice area than it is to like Montana
so it's a little bit south but my whole
experience was uh I like felt like
everyone at my school was just normal
kids because there was a lot of a lot of
you know underprivileged people who went
to same aha because that area wasn't
necessarily it's about the richest area
yeah it's a school and there's lots of
options for charter schools and private
schools here where I imagine all the
[ __ ] absolutely and those were
that's that's my experience after the
[ __ ] exactly and I don't want to
name names but I kind of do know but
like so those are the private schools
like we played in baseball we would
always really have an easy time with
them because their programs were like
really underdeveloped but yeah those
kids I mean yeah and for all you across
the board though I don't know what like
in my mind I sort of had this thing that
like everyone in Los Angeles was like
Malibu Barbie and Ken and like well
that's I mean it's it's not a unfair
misconception but I also never been here
until I was like 23 years old yeah I
thought the entire estate was just
Disney okay you know what I mean though
you just have this sort of like crazy
misconception yeah about what things are
so I think it's a valid question for
someone that's not from here but it
sounds like you know a lot like what how
everyone grows up in America at least
where you know you have public schools
and then there's some tea bags there but
this is not most of this
not that everyone goes to the charter
school at private schools to stop no but
if the that's good super super super
expensive ones yeah that's where I feel
like there's a higher population of well
yeah I mean cuz kids get raised given
things you know I mean they don't have
to work for I would like to point out my
two best friends like when I was growing
up as a kid Scott and Tyler Hyneman I
play baseball with them all you know all
through my youth and now they're you
know Tyler's playing professional
baseball Scott's had organ or whatever
and he's going to get drafted soon but
the whole point is that they went to
private schools and they were like
seriously some of the most down-to-earth
cool kids that I ever hung out with and
I would literally spend weekends at
their house and they would spend
weekends amanna we would play baseball
non-stop but I guess what I'm trying to
say is like yeah there's like a lot of
but you know kind of I don't know how to
say this but I guess there's all the
signs when you when you put a kid in
private school point to turning that kid
into kind of like a reliant entitled kid
yeah go ahead yeah no and and I just
think that you know a good kid who's
raised well no matter what happens you
know where they go to school whatever
they're gonna be good people for sure
you know I just think sometimes like a
good normal kid that's put into an
environment where they feel a lot of
pressure or they feel left out because
you don't [ __ ] have everything that
everyone else has it makes it harder to
you know not resent things yeah I mean
you put you're kind of in an environment
where you're like everyone else is like
richer than me like they're really smart
the parents are doctors and like guys
I'm [ __ ] white trash over here yeah
yeah yeah absolutely but I'm it's
totally not surprising at all that
normal people can do that and be fine
but back to the original point yeah um I
think it's interesting shut up um that
oh my god marble be quiet I think it's
interesting that the adults that live
here are so outrageously like not normal
no
and yet they can be not normal and breed
kids that are insanely normal cuz you're
like one of the most normal people I've
ever met
and and you were born and raised here
yeah but your parents aren't no my
parents are you scold your parents and
they're super Downers to doughnuts
Boston regulary York yeah um yeah I
don't know I mean I guess I guess it
goes back to like you know I could have
been raised in Rochester like you my
parents would have raised me the same
way right no yeah absolutely yeah so um
but it is odd because I mean you don't
realize this until you know I I finished
college I didn't go to college and all
la you know I finished college and now
I'm an adult living in LA or I have been
and you go out and you meet people and
all sorts of walks of life whatever
you're doing you're at a bar anywhere
whatever you do and it you're right like
it's so often that you encounter these
adults who you are like how are you the
way that you are right and they're like
oh man I'm from I'm from Boston I'm from
Chicago I'm from like these insanely
cool normal places and I'm like yeah but
you suck does not compute
like did you suck before you moved here
or did you suck after you moved they're
both very good possibilities because you
know as graduate maybe Los Angeles is
just a [ __ ] black hole and it sucks
all of the sucky people into it so they
sucked before they moved here and
they've drawn to this [ __ ] negative
energy Los Angeles just attracts the
suck it sucks in the suck well you meet
a lot of people here that are just so
like they'll do anything yeah any it's
very very uh it just turns you off man
you meet people like that and it's just
kind of like I think you've said this
before when you may be like that like
ruins it for everyone else it ruins it
um but I want to say the strongest thing
that I noticed there was like a stark
contrast to anything I've ever
experienced in my life was when I moved
to Santa Monica
yeah the first thing that I noticed was
that there's no you know you never see
any people like in the neighborhoods I
was like there's never
kids playing outside like no-one's like
there's no kids I guess is my point okay
there's no little kids running around
and nobody's riding their bike because
in Rochester and in Boston like where I
lived in Cambridge
there's just forever [ __ ] kids
playing basketball and skateboarding
down the street and like if it's snowing
they're [ __ ] sledding on things they
should you know there's just a plethora
of children yeah like in California you
never with these with the exception of
the two dicks next door they never
invite us to play basketball yeah you
never see any kids outside yeah like
we're all your [ __ ] kids well where
did you play when you're a kid um I mean
you played on the school yards after
school honestly I think like if you if
you were playing basketball or if you're
playing baseball you play Little League
you play at the park basketball if you
want to stay after school
extracurriculars and stuff you do it on
campus like uh after school like living
on your yard you know I really had that
big of a yard that's whai'm see it's
it's a different kind of community
because in out in Rochester you know
people have yards it's bigger there's
more space between house and stuff like
that but here it's more like compact
like houses streets you know I mean
businesses so I think the fact that you
don't see a lot of kids playing around
in their houses isn't necessarily so
much because kids don't play here but
it's more because you're playing it's no
no I know sit around play video games no
it's like I think they're just playing
elsewhere they playing on the school
playgrounds or playing in so we're more
fun to play yeah like there's more
things here I mean it's like they're
lucky they have gems they have all sorts
of you know places at their disposal as
kids which is I mean it's very awesome
it's very fortunate as a kid you know
who was raised here and kids who get to
play and all that stuff you know but
yeah I think you know I like when you
ask me if I've ever played like on a
yarder self like besides like the
trampoline I had in my back
yeah when I was growing up we never like
ran around in each other's yards like we
would keep that to like you know yeah
that's all they are dead and and like
woods and [ __ ] cuz it you know we when
you're a little kid it's not like your
parents can [ __ ] up and drive you
because it's it's not like in Santa
Monica where you can drive literally ten
minutes and get to somewhere really
awesome yeah yeah I'm Rochester like if
you me if you want to go somewhere
really awesome it's like twenty thirty
or forty minutes away and your mom's
like nah dude it's [ __ ] Saturday go
outside and play with yourself yeah
and that's see that's a whole different
you know culture that you yeah I mean it
was fun but it was it was crazy when I
moved here I was like there's never any
kids outside playing it makes me feel
weird yeah well don't feel weird I just
wish that those [ __ ] kids man you
know what I think tomorrow before I
leave I'm Sheena dunk on just go over
there and [ __ ] I'm gonna dunk on a man
[ __ ] 360 just like pull down their
hoop and then leave and then empty the
water out of the base of it [ __ ] yeah
you're weird as kids though and those
people that next are weird ask people to
so I have 8 million [ __ ] cars that
block the entire street yeah I don't
want to get started on their [ __ ]
anything there's and then yelling late
at night in different languages I keep
it yourself man yeah but it but it's not
just that maybe your pants neighbor
every single window in their house is
open 24/7 fish screens there's a little
boy that was there that sings at the top
of his lungs but he sounds like a little
girl
yeah he's cuz he's a little [ __ ] oh my
god uh no but and then then windows also
look down it's like it looks directly
into her she's so fun so he screamed the
last time I heard of me was scream
singing Sia's chandelier and I was like
oh my god can I try to picture that try
to picture what that's like to live next
to
but he's screaming it like down into the
yard it's like pissing the dogs off I'm
like dude qith come on come on but no
need there's no need for that kid you
can be bringing your talents else
we're in the house or out of the house
you can be playing basketball you can be
doing your damn home at least like if
you're gonna scream sing like go into a
room where you could shut a door or I
just fall it's the [ __ ] parents man
parents ha parents ha ha
pairen how do i parent I feel like if
you're gonna leave every screen in your
hot in your house open there should be
like a strict indoor voices policy yeah
giancarlo they do not have that they
have a scream voice policy with all the
windows open and yeah it [ __ ] it
makes me feel weird because I feel like
I can hear they're like arguments like
their conversations and I'm Way too much
and then we hit too much I feel like I'm
learning a new language and I don't
wanna I'm like starting to understand
what they're saying to each other and
what I'm ging glish to I'm not saying
the only speak a Tamilian cuz he's
singing chandelier that's English no
I've met that woman that lives there she
speaks English oh that met the dad too
but I heard someone yelling in something
which I think he was talking about
dinner but I you know I don't know it
could just be the [ __ ] I don't know Oh
God
but that's no longer anything cuz we
were leaving this [ __ ] place yeah
well we'll still be equally as close to
neighbors but hopefully yeah I mean
although the people next door do have a
dog so we could start a barking war yeah
marble yeah right right well we're gonna
be what did he be excited to find out
that there's a barking dog next huh no
he's gonna lose his little bit but
that's innocent away it's like exciting
cuz he like he lives for that [ __ ] he
does any me they saw a [ __ ] squirrel
earlier today and it was like the
[ __ ] dog barking apocalypse
yeah and Kermit Kermit does this
different Park
Frigga you know I was like oh it's like
he's a quietest dog ever
and he never the world cuz he's state
hound
I know season yeah he's like all he can
do is focus on how to get it
Kermit it's up in a tree bro Kermit
figure it out man figured out man
fobba-liscious fobba-liscious o Belize's
fobba-liscious
ya [ __ ] for those of you that
geographically don't understand with a
neon no where where the valley is it's
beyond so Los Angeles is like down here
Santa Monica's like here don't have
Malibu and then there's a mountain range
yep San Bernardino man right yep oh yeah
whatever
I mean it might be I don't know that and
then beyond that is the San Fernando
Valley yes keep going that's the
Calabasas Woodland Hills and Tarzana and
see no and then like Sherman Oaks
further out it's like West Hills Studio
City
Ben eyes all that yeah yeah yeah uh-huh
you hit that pretty well thanks I've
been looking at a lot of men people
people refer to like the valley or
Studio City or Sherman Oaks like as over
the hill so you're like oh you're gonna
go over the hill that's where that is
you go over that little mountain range
bounty on range yes it's it's fairly
quick with no traffic but it's a great
area and a nice make cheaper because
people think that it's [ __ ] you know
it's way cheaper you get more free money
there's a stigma against the valley yeah
there is from women valley i don't know
i don't know why but um i don't know why
you turds dope it is [ __ ] hot out
there yeah well I was gonna say is like
the nine trips we've taken
I mean we've taken trips like Tuesday
night Wednesday night Thursday night you
know - Friday night whatever like yeah
throughout the week it's poppin' yeah
there's like late-night cafes there's
like bars I mean it's it looks like a
fun places like young people that looks
more fun than we live now we live now is
like serious it's in Los Angeles but
it's like a neighborhood it's like
residential of residential yeah nobody
[ __ ] does Shh we're like south of
what's happening in Westwood cuz in
Westwood there's the Westwood Village
where there's a couple bars yeah but
yeah and you say so even if we were like
a little north in Westwood we would have
the the village but still that's not our
scene like we don't really you know me
like I feel like Studio City out there
is way more appropriate for us well yeah
they're young professionals yeah you're
not quite students that don't want to go
out and just like get sloshed Istanbul
around yeah you don't want to be
half-naked you sort of just want to have
like a nice a couple drinks enjoy yeah
and like it seems it seems miniscule the
difference between college students in
just out of college or you know late
twenties or whatever but it is a big
difference in the way people go out you
know you go to college bars and it's
just like a totally different experience
and it is something like young working
people well the bar that we used to
frequent when we lived look around here
uh I think that they might let them
under underage people yeah like it just
gets really sloppy and that's why like I
really liked it because they played
great [ __ ] music and they really
awesome bartenders - yeah and like like
just really dope music and like a really
sweaty crowded dance floor and I was
like yes this is div' and [ __ ]
awesome yeah and I loved it but then you
know as you start to go there more and
more and more you're like well II
there's people here that I'm not sure
are 21 years old and it's getting like
too sloppy even for me you know yeah
yeah yeah and I'm sort of whatever like
haha you know who the [ __ ] is yes but
there's a lot of sloppy things yeah yep
it's fun for what it is but you know
yeah that's absolutely true
I'm except I'm honestly excited but I'm
also intrigued as to what we're gonna
find out there you name what it's gonna
be like bum I'm psyched man I'm it's
crazy how stressful like your living
area is like your your little like
[ __ ] hermit crab you know yeah how
your shell of now see you yeah yeah mom
it's very stressful it's all very
stressful
after our hermit crab conversation last
week someone tweeted a picture of a
hermit crab
with a clear shell what so you can see
like no that's a thing it's artificial
like it no what you say anything I've
ever heard they put it on yeah it's you
know it's no you could just put the
shell in the cage and it will move
itself into the cage or into this you're
not saying it's right I'm just trying to
clarify that this was done by a human
penis
yeah like do you understand how upset
like that my inner child is right now
that I shouldn't have said that to you
oh my god I mean come on they do cut all
kinds of crazy testing on animals that's
like the least of your worries
what do you mean testing messing around
with artificially alters I'm just saying
because we used to stay up for hours and
hours and hours after shower there
trying to look like so then you could
just give them a clear shell and then
you can see what they look like yeah I
see what you're saying okay you had it
rough ER yeah child yeah well what a
blow I was just dealt better late than
never
no it's worse late than never it's worse
late it's worse at all should never have
happened
are you talking about can you show me a
picture can you put bring up oh I don't
it's deep in my mentions how awful to
show you after we'll pull it up I'll
send you all send you guys a link it is
I'll put the link like right right there
or something man huh
um but yeah so just wanted to remind you
that what a slap in the [ __ ] face man
I'm dying over here it's gonna be all
right
you're gonna recover it was gonna be all
right mm-hmm
dude I told you the story about my
brother like some things that just make
you so outrageously sad in the moment
but like you know it's silly and you
know that you shouldn't be that sad but
yes you can control yeah yeah I told
Julian this story I think before but
like on Saturdays me and my brother used
to sleep in late you know I would sleep
in too like nine or ten yeah that's a
Devon would sleep in until like 1:00
because he's a couple years older and
he's gigantic and a teenage boy needed
all the sleep in the world but I used to
like you know
Zana look Devin get up in the middle of
the day God now all I everyone is like
yeah please please can I sleep until
forever um so my mom used to get us
toaster strudels which are like the
little pastry that you put in the
toaster and then it comes with a little
thing of frosting and they're [ __ ]
amazing and me my brother loved them
would save them like for the weekends so
that we could eat him and have fun oh we
can do this util we so um I woke up
early you know 10 9 or 10 and I go to
the freezer open it up there's you know
a box of toaster strudels there's like
one in it but usually we had like a
couple boxes in there so I take the
toaster shoot a lot cook it and I'm
sitting there eating it and then Devin
wakes up and uh he goes and looks in the
freezer and he opens it up and he's like
he looks at my toaster strudel and he
looks in the freezer he goes now there's
nothing special for me to eat and I just
like like the toaster sure was like
coming out of my mouth I was like oh
like crying so [ __ ] hard I couldn't
[ __ ] handle it was like the saddest
thing in the whole world
georgeanna felt so guilty last toaster
strudel and uh yeah my mom was like
dying laughing and then Devin started
laughing and like you guys don't
understand I think I just feel so bad
I'm the [ __ ] I think we've all
absolutely had this moments where ya
know how ridiculous is what you
absolutely can't control it and also
knowing Devin I can I can hear him
saying jewelry that's really funny um
I'm sure you just [ __ ] ate like made
some 10 bowls of cereal he would feel
like a you know something like a mixing
bowl full of cereal and just sit there
that's how I eat cereal - um yeah I like
cried and cried cried about that I'm so
sad I'm sorry it's okay but that's
that's what that little [ __ ] clear
hermit crab shell just made me feel like
oh don't cry I just I have something
special to eat it so shake it I wish I
could go back to little
and be like some well hopefully
hopefully China will recover so many
hours I want those hours of my life back
you know I was staring at a crowd whose
bonding time with you in Devon that's
why you're so close I told you about the
time that her gerbils had babies right
yeah you did I think yeah Devon thought
they were carrots cuz the light was up i
I used to make fun of him cuz we had we
got two gerbils we thought were boys the
the pet store tell us they were boys and
I named mine Snoopy or snoop and he
named his sleepy head
there's this big black gerbil and I was
always like you're dribbles so much
fatter than mine like your dribbles so
fat Devon he would be slickest shut up
new noise noise he's all just bigger
he's more of a man than yours and then
they were in the cage together in my
room I was like mom did we feed the
gerbils carrots and she turns on the
light and there's like 700 [ __ ]
babies like 50 years so but by the
morning then there were only like eight
does they eat them yeah they eat the
babies did you know that
yeah like you'll eat the ones oh my god
they eat the ones that they can't take
care yeah yeah so far yeah so I was like
alright in the morning we'll take him to
the pet store and wake up I'm like
where's my 15 babies oh my god oh my god
that must have been weeds but it was
like such a [ __ ] like if we talk
about sad moment versus Jenna's happy
wind childhood moment I was like haha
David I told you your gerbils fat
because it's a chick and my knockers up
told you damn you're pure gerbil totally
was bad just full of fighting 15 babies
that soon turned into eight oh and then
dinner I know I saw her eating one
that's why I like carrots a lot like who
just like dumped a bag of baby carrots
in the dribble okay oh oh
every time I get baby carrots and the
grocery store I'm going to think of
their dribbles from now on yep well I
hope you guys enjoyed that story because
I'm gonna feel that way every time he
cares now
you'll be all right what is she doing
she's like trying to escape through the
neck she doesn't have any regard that
this shirt is gonna get stretched out
you're naughty naughty naughty oh I know
I like I I do like though when we have
an idea of a podcast and we start
talking to a completely different
totally different I enjoy that
good work yeah good work I hope you guys
aren't mad if we have to end well yeah
better than soon have this be a short
podcast
it'll be shorter but you know we got to
do it we gotta move we gotta move we
gotta finish moving I promise you guys
are gonna be happy when we're back all
settled in a real house again with all
this [ __ ] and we're gonna have a cool
move a cool podcast area set up yeah we
will do our best so we'll make it look
good for you probably still at this
table probably still have to stay with
this table so great but um thank you
guys for hanging out with us
yeah and for being tolerant of us being
tired and and at our at our physical
limit of yeah thing you guys are awesome
it's very supportive I appreciate it
yeah we're on iTunes we're on all the
stuff you know that you know the drill
we'll see you guys next week
just know any of your thoughts about
what we talked about always contribute
my least favorite part about packing is
what what you hate the most about your
neighbors or you [ __ ] or like
something stupid sad or stupid head
exactly all right or what you think
about people that live in Los Angeles
and your theory on why some of this
sucks so bad exactly that's a great
conversation we need to have with you
yeah all right what did the dick say to
the [ __ ] you [ __ ]
why don't you have bows somewhere
apparent ease bubblicious what are you
what do you say to three whales what
well well well we here
where do you fall no because no legs you
use all these on XMR Wow my job nachos
what is it out in samuel l.jackson stand
for what [ __ ]
alright that's that's all folks
yeah but what's the population of Brazil
I don't know pretty big probably about a
brazilian people okay probably about of
brazilian see you guys I'm so good just
special special job good jugs special
special dance we are going to go be
rupee somewhere else now okay but my